thank you
hot breath what's up hot breath the
verse
welcome back this is your host comedian
Joel Byers today
hot Brethren and cistern
we have one of our legendary guests it's
been since 2015 since we've interviewed
this cat the first time around we were
interviewing him about all of his
experiences working with people like
George Lopez and Monique and Tyler Perry
and building his own International brand
and now
three years later is that three years
what's today's date this is 2019 2015.
three year I have a liberal arts degree
long story short this is about to be a
comedy master class for my comedy master
so you're definitely going to want to
take notes in my opinion this gentleman
is a Yoda of Comedy so he is going to
help us all today with just taking our
comedy to the next level not only on the
stage but also in the boardroom so
prepare yourselves for a comedy master
class with the one
with the only
Rodney Perry everybody Rodney Perry and
if you do enjoy this one of course hot
breath the verse do give us a shout out
let us know on social media you can
share on there also connect with us
personally on our personal Facebook
group we have hot breadth Comedy Network
on there you can connect with fans and
also
other listeners and we share a lot of
fun insights over there as well so
definitely keep up with us and shoot me
an email with any questions you may have
or any content you'd like to see us
creating Joel byerscomedy gmail.com the
more we can connect the more we can grow
and the more impact we can have on
Comedy together so
without further ado
hot brother and sister and let us
welcome to the hot breathaverse the one
the only the legendary
Rodney Perry everybody what's up buddy
we out here
all right you got your mic you got a mic
did I give you Mike oh I didn't give you
a mic there you go buddy
I was like maybe you don't want me to
talk I'm not gonna say nothing until I
get me a microphone it's been so long
what's up JB what's good buddy so did I
just give you a nickname do do people
call you JB JB I've been called that
before yeah that would be cool you don't
go but you don't you're not a JB I'm not
I'm you're Joel I'm Joel I'm trying to
Brandon to Joe Byers yeah you the whole
thing yeah you're not just Joel your job
you absolutely I'm Rodney Perry I'm not
Rodney well my goal is too though when
people hear the name Joel they then
default to me you're the only Joe
there's an Osteen Joel Osteen but right
now he sees the name he's definitely the
top of the Google Search
right now though right now right now for
the time being yeah yeah he's the head
Joel but that's why we're interviewing
you today hoping um you can share
insights on how we can build this Empire
right right man I'm I'm trying to figure
it out too man and yeah you know I think
more than anything is just um you know
people start to throw words around at
you when you've been around for a while
you know so I had a comic say Legend and
that's kind of off-putting but I receive
it at the same time you know because
you become a legend if you just don't
quit
um you know what I mean okay is there is
there I can turn that off is there music
going on that's Madden I'm sorry that's
Madden that's John Madden football hold
on
hold on sorry guys
my grown guest has to turn down his
Madden game really quick
[Music]
hilarious
and I'll give you some water too we've
we've got our own branded water sense
last time you were here we got some
fontus local Georgia spring water
ice Joe
wow get out of here you sell these I
would I do people can go on
hotbreathpodcast.com contribute a
donation and they get a um a water
bottle get out is that you is you are
you the white guy in the in
yeah that's me I'm the white guy that
guy looks like
Dick Van Dyke
that's what that's what my wife said too
yeah really yeah yeah she did say that
does she know who Dick Van Dyke is
uh-huh get out of here yeah she's OG she
is absolutely good for her
you're married now dude I am the last
time we talked you weren't married no no
you guys were talking about it and uh
wow I remember I was having some
conversation so good how is it I love it
yeah because she's being married
there's nothing like having somebody
that gives it to him for real yeah yeah
yeah yeah you know that really cares are
you okay are you okay Joel
and and really wants to know yeah and
motivate you absolutely that's some of
my biggest advice I'd give to uh lonely
Comics out there just get married
and if you find new motivation at the
very least it's good for an hour
material right right yeah yeah yeah if
if for no other reason get married for
the jokes and a dog cause I've got a dog
announcer got a dog yeah you guys are
real deal family she's closing in on me
it's over so Checkmate let me tell you
something you got the last move you want
to just lay down the Checkmate is the
baby
you think yeah how old are you 31. oh
yeah he's still young uh but you know
you you're getting into the window where
you don't you you you could be an old
dad
yeah but I want to have money before I
have a kid uh kids bring money you have
you have money to
kids will come with us my mother used to
always say this uh my wife and I
remember uh I was you know budding up
becoming comedian we had already had one
child and we just got financially stable
and we had another one on the way and I
remember just being frustrated and I
talked to my mom
and I was like Mom you know I don't know
what I'm gonna do I got a baby coming
and I don't know how I'm gonna take care
of this baby she said babies come with
blessings hmm babies and I stopped and I
looked at my children I was like yo each
kid brought a certain diary if you will
and they all come with a blessing my my
my uh my first daughter got us our first
apartment in Inglewood California my
second daughter we moved into a
two-bedroom my third daughter we we end
up in a three bedroom and our baby now
got us this house whoa absolutely
we're in the theater we got some chairs
maybe that's what I'm missing because
you got to let let them soldiers go man
[Laughter]
okay good stuff he's like yeah man I'll
be shooting up the club every night I'm
like shooting up the club that's how you
make life that's that's the new term is
that what he tells his wife too he's
like yeah I'm shooting up the club for
our family
hey I guess I guess well if that's the
secret man because that's where I'm at
in my career right now is I'm nine years
in and now I know in perspective of this
is my life like I'm doing this for the
rest of my life comedy but nine years in
I'm like all right I've been doing it
long enough towards time
start making money
true enough you know what I mean like
and I'm not I'm not trying to sound
ungrateful or impatient because I know
this this whole game is a marathon and
not a Sprint true but I am ready to
start putting in some infrastructure at
least to start actually generating
income and not just paying dues and
you've already kind of begun to do that
and we all have to make the paradigm
shift because this is a business and you
know you inherently are an artist
so when you're an artist you just want
to paint you just want to do your art
and the shift comes when you go okay I'm
an artist I would probably do this for
free for the rest of my life but I
really would like to pay the light bill
right and the life bill is coming again
and again and again so
um it's it's a mental shift which which
it sounds like you've already made so
the mental shift is
um
being a headliner
uh or committing to being a feature uh
you know uh making a plan
you know the the things that's comedians
we kind of don't do you know we kind of
just kind of wing it but the more you
could plan the better you'll the better
you'll be equipped to see where you are
on your as you as you approach your
goals if you don't make a plan you don't
even know when you're approaching your
goal
so um yeah I've I've done those things
throughout my career and it was moments
when I wasn't doing any of it
you know and I can look back go man that
I could have been way more productive
during that stretch of my life had I
been more focused
and so how did you dial in that Focus
what shift did you make
um wow great great question how did how
did I dial in the focus
you know it might have been a friend it
might have been you know seeing somebody
else it might have been uh any number of
things and then you have to remind
yourself even once you know you still
got to remind yourself to do it you know
so so
um
dialing in that focus is is really about
just you got to take a step back and
look at your life and be like okay uh
like I'm not where I want to be so
my My Philosophy has always been get
busy like whenever I'm at a loss I just
try to do something else whatever you
know I try to adjust you know I I play
John Madden football and that's a great
metaphor for me personally because when
a guy is beating you in the game there's
always something you can do some
adjustments you can make and life is the
same way you can always you feel like
you're losing you're down you can always
win because there's a there's a light a
little shift that can affect everything
and so for me that shift is always get
busy so like say for instance you know
starting the beginning of the year
I I learned over my career to manage
time better and what I mean when I do
that when I say that like I manage my
year so
say we're in first quarter you know like
and 4 500 companies do this too first
quarter 2019
Rodney Perry needs to be working so
guess what I got to be thinking about
first quarter in September hmm like I
can't wait till December when
everybody's off work going Christmas to
think about what I'm going to be doing
January February March so I'm thinking
about first quarter then and now January
February March I'm thinking okay spring
okay uh what do I have that's going to
Splash and spring so I can further not
only not only got to do stuff but I got
to do stuff that that that's uh
far-reaching
so for me personally this year I just
wrote my first book oh wow just finished
my book I call it the original title was
100 moments on my journey and as I wrote
The Moments out I had a list of 130
moments so I changed the time of the
moments on my journey and you constantly
get tools though like uh a friend of
mine who's an author I called her I was
like I got this book in my mind I wrote
an outline which the item what I written
out amounted to a great outline
and she was like okay she gave me a tool
she said use this website it's called
teame.com right t-e-m-i Timmy Timmy
transformed my spoken word into type
work so now I can write my book without
physically typing
so
a book that would have took me six
months to write I wrote in two weeks
I know the stories you know uh I know
the moments so it was a I was able to
kind of get through it and it was really
cathartic because as I as I was recall
in certain moments of my life
you know recount things I could have
done that better I could have did this
better but
it was stuff that I forgotten and so as
I was going through the process I was
like yo looking at my life and it just
opened me up now now I'm writing all the
time because I'm like you know whether
it's with a pen and paper or I'm typing
or I'm I'm talking to my phone I'm
constantly kind of creating I'm in a
really great creative space and as as
comedians we go in and out of those
spaces so you gotta you gotta stay in
the creative space longer if you can you
know I I'm I'm curious to hear even how
maybe far back you were planning to
write this book because you're talking
about creating a plan and having like a
destination so is this something you
thought of years ago you finally
implemented yeah I I it's been on my
bucket list for some time
um but I I don't want to front like I
was like uh beginning 2019 and write a
book no I I knew I wanted to write the
book I came up with a title maybe at
least two years ago but but the the
prospect of typing a book was a daunting
task for me and so I was like yo man I'm
not I can't do that and I was just
finding reasons not to do it and so
um
just like a few like maybe five years
ago when I wrote my first short film I I
try to get myself attainable goals right
like I try to say like when I start
writing a short film I was like I just
want to write five pages
if I can write five pages I'll be happy
and five pages turned into ten Pages
turned into 28 pages and I let my buddy
read it who's a director he said right
now you have to shoot this so next thing
I know I'm shooting right producing
director in my own short film so uh if
you can create
the universal kind of move out your way
to get it done okay you know it's like
with this I can remember you starting
this and because you started this you've
become an expert in this field
you know you could teach a class on how
to do this yeah which is another screen
income that's what I'm looking for I'm
looking for the streams and on our first
interview you said people should have
seven streams yeah that that's that's
that's that's a school of thought we
should have seven streams of income but
this is the thing about us like I mean
let's talk money yes you already got it
like because we dealing intellectual
property so you've probably you're
probably sitting on a million plus
dollars worth of ideas
you know what I mean so if you're like
me Rodney Perry is the idea guy I come
up with ideas all day my dilemma is
keeping people around me to help me
Implement those ideas
so uh I think probably a good place to
start for us today is like team building
like who's on your team who's who's
helping you who wants to help you that
you're not paying attention to like
those other people that you need to lock
into because like I my sister she has a
unique skill set her degree is in
logistics and planning and so
she was just my little sister to me
and we got to talk one day and I was
like wow you do that
I need that
and
and you just gotta know that it's people
in your life that's probably already
there so again it's always life is
perspective you sometimes just got to
step back go oh [__] I got I got the
person that needs to help me right there
it might be your wife it might be a
girlfriend I personally don't like
working with my wife okay she too bossy
she was knocking on the door what are
you doing down there who bossy
so building the team that could be step
one I think so I think so building a
team of course starting with with you
you know I meet a lot of young comments
he's like man I need a man who who's a
good manager I'm like first of all you
don't know how how to manage you yet
like if you are a business
would you turn the Reigns over to your
business to anybody before you knew how
to how to how to CEO if you're hiring a
manager you're the CEO so you need to
know their job
right so
you you definitely need a manager when
you have something to manage
gold hey that's gold gotta have
something something to manage hey man I
see I see tons of people you know don't
have nothing to damn manage out there
with a manager splitting fifty dollars
right right right right how you get
somebody 10 or 50.
stop
so even thinking of in money and what
I've been kind of and this is my first
year I'm glad you brought up goals
because this is my first year of my
career I have made specific measurable
goals okay like I have a financial goal
I want to hit I have like um a specific
goal with festivals for this podcast of
getting into like measurable goals
understood so I've taken inventory on
all the different things I'm doing and
then now I'm trying to figure out how to
I guess turn it into a business or turn
it into like money really with all the
education that's going on I'm teaching
some classes this is educational this
podcast we're doing so I'm brainstorming
and trying to think of ways and my
vision is to have like a comedy School
and not only in person but also online
through like webinars right various I I
definitely want to get in that web space
as well
um the more passive income you can
create the better like you know you know
I don't know if you're like me but like
I kind of need to do everything which is
the wrong way to approach any business
you know
billionaires don't physically do
anything
there but but the the usually the the
stuff that they yield they they can set
the wheels in motion so uh webinars I
think is a great idea Great Space to get
in and you can create it one time and it
could live years Beyond yeah yeah it's
true you know
um so
I to the short answer I'm trying to get
into that space as well I think it's a
great space to be in and the hard part
is is realizing what you're selling like
I have an improv Workshop right and I
was talking to one of my buddies he's an
entrepreneur and he we had these great
conversations we go back and forth on on
business and you know again your team is
is people that kind of make you better
and he's always given me these these
Jewels right and he's like Rodney you're
not selling Improv
you're selling
a brand of motivation
so when I teach my improv workshop I'll
tell you I'm not teaching you improv I'm
teaching you how to trust your choices
if you trust your choices you'll be kind
of better at everything improv is just
one of the things you'll be pretty good
at and it's the tool I use but but
ultimately you'll be better at
on your feet making quick choices I can
help you with that and so
that's essentially empowerment right
it's just wrapped in improv so how do I
how do I package that for webinars
social media Facebook Twitter Instagram
YouTube it can be done and uh that's
that's one of the things we're working
on right now so you would almost re like
even the advertising you would re kind
of reword it to be more based on like
not improv but more of just motivation
or self-sufficiency maybe maybe I mean
that's that's kind of the idea as we're
trying to figure it out I'm figuring out
as we speak like oh wow I got I got a A
friend of mine that's helping me with
some branding of it because he came and
watched me I'm in a class right now I
partnered with DFAS which is an acting
studio here in Atlanta and uh it's been
a great partnership to this point so um
DFAS and and and I have taken the never
deny Next Level improv workshop and
really expanded it and at the same time
I'm trying to expand it even more
because it's one of those things that
anybody can do
you know so I'm trying to figure it out
man
it's interesting to hear someone at the
level of your career saying I'm still
trying to figure it out too yes sir yes
sir that is enlightening for people
listening who are like like me or even
like a year or two in where it's like oh
at every level we're still
I mean every
every goal you achieve will open the
door to another goal okay it's just what
it is I mean you know when you when you
get that dollar value we talked about
you said you set your goal you want to
achieve the Dollar by when you get that
money you'd be like
I mean I mean more actually if if I'm
really honest with myself I actually
need more than that like like I I I
definitely set monetary goals throughout
the year but more than that like
my goals like I don't even realize the
money I've made till I stop and do my
taxes or I stop and I look I look at you
know I know what my I know it cost to
run my life per month
and you do that times 12 and you're like
yo we did we had a pretty good year
we're not kicked out right we got to be
killing it so so
uh another tip it is just just take some
time man and take inventory of of your
wins
you know because we're so busy to get to
the next win that we don't have we never
celebrate the wind
you know you're winning dude you mean
you gotta you got a great podcast you
got listenership you got you got people
that that are envying the hot breadth of
verse
that's a good deal man so so don't
forget to to go Joe Barnes you're doing
good
yeah because he needs that we need that
yeah I guess reinforcement absolutely
you're walking your journey absolutely I
mean and dude the crazy part people
would swap places with us I mean we're
sitting here at
noon
on a Friday
and this is probably all you got
anything else to do today yeah I have a
call I got to do you got a call so you
got to make a phone call
it's a writing I do like I do like I
help people with the writing and
punching up stuff so I have one of those
this afternoon
and they got to pay you for that yes
come on man so it's somebody at a
cubicle that wants to murder both of
them
that's crazy that is that is a good
perspective to have but even when you're
starting when you because now we're
almost thinking of more high level uh
trying to build this business in this
brand but
even I'm I'm also at a point where I'm
looking to get booked more like I've
like I like how you said it's a mind
shift whether you're a headliner you're
only if or you're a feature now is like
I've turned down hosting stuff
because I am like in the mindset of I'm
at least a feature now like I can't go
down and just stay there you have to
change your mind before you change your
position uh when I when I was uh
I made I made a couple of decisions back
to back so I was in the Navy from 90 to
98 at 1998 I was at a Crossroads I was
either going to continue on in the Navy
do do four more years which would have
took me to 12 and if I had done 12 I
would have had to do 20 in my mind I was
a math and so I was like yo
um I got to get out I'd already kind of
decided but I hadn't done it yet so I I
got out
but that's just part of it so you get
out and now you have to actually start
doing it
you have to actually start doing that
thing that you said you were going to do
and so I got out but I still kind of
wasn't doing it I was doing all kind of
other stuff just to make ends meet and
and and so
as I as I stepped out on faith
the other step was mentally so I decided
and this is a very conscious decision
I'm a headliner now
yeah now everybody wouldn't book me
but it was a few people that respected
me that would book me as a headline and
iron one time I realized you can't
relinquish that either
so one of one of my buddies he was he
was a comedian he's very funny and he
was like Rod you headline all the time
let me headline tonight but he hadn't
really earned that spot yet
you know what it's all good but it
wasn't and he did well but I I learned
that night that you never relinquish
that thing that you work for like you
don't yield
to give that up because you made the
shift in your mind and so it just didn't
feel good to me and so uh whether it's
featuring or whatever it is you have to
decide
and once you decide then you start doing
it
like you got to make the choice here
first you have to
and I've done it so I'm not just
arbitrarily saying I know it works too
so when you make that mind shift what is
the next step do you start would you
start reaching out to Bookers as a
headliner like what was your what was
your next step you you make the Mind
shift now what is the actual physical
how do you implement it yeah so so so
you make the Mind shift and
and this might be sounds like some
metaphysical mumbo jumbo but people just
start calling
people start calling and or or you may
have and you may have to turn some stuff
down
you may have to turn some stuff down and
the thing about offers is if a person
called you they'll call again
like you and you had to just trust that
and it's and don't get me wrong
what people don't what people don't
understand is sometimes the light
Builders do
and the light bills do the the gig you
would have turned down had you had that
bill paid you might take
and and so we have those gray areas but
as you make that that choice
that I am this now
your first implementation is probably
turning down anything lesser than that
and and Beyond and beyond that it the
rest of the stuff kind of just makes its
way to you
like so
um I don't know if I'm being clear
answer wise but
you just kind of have to trust it
that it's gonna work you know it's going
to work and and it'll be some tough days
you know I think I think at some point
God just expects you to trust him
like you had to either you trust me you
don't mm-hmm if you're worrying about
if you worried at all it's not a good
thing
yeah you mean you're making sense
because I remember even when I first
pursued comedy full-time like I saved up
ten thousand dollars not enough there's
never enough money you can save a
million dollars and you'll blow through
that in three days
it got me a long way though really ten
thousand I mean I was working at
Enterprise Rent-A-Car got it and then as
soon as I hit that 10 000 Mark I quit
and then took on I didn't quit that was
a part of a plan though I mean you
didn't just say I got ten thousand I'm
quitting no it was and I'll take a
lesser job so then I went into Hotel I
became a hotel mini bar attendant nice
so I just went around many bars
refilling those and um bringing home
dinner every night as well but I took I
love it so you had all type of cookies
and snacks from the mini bar yeah and
Trail I went on a little I went on a
little three-run tour with a couple of
comics we had an almost grown-ups tour
uh it was just the three of us love it
and um that whole trip we went up like
through Missouri and like came back
around I think through like Huntsville
and then came home and that whole trip I
ate nothing but Cliff Bars really it
Cliff Bars from the mini bars get out of
here you were you had a Naked and Afraid
diet it was amazing
like I'm always impressed when I hear
stories like that because that's the
stuff people don't hear is like people
think this looks glamorous when you see
the big Comics it looks really glamorous
but you know we all were there eating
those Cliff Bars eating hot Cheetos and
and staying at ratty hotels it was a run
when I first made the choice to get out
of the Navy and so I was a headliner I
made up my mind I'm a headliner and
my last feature job
was
I did a tour uh this guy named Dave
Tribble used to do a run I've heard a
lot of comics talk about the famous
triple run I did a triple run and and so
I was living in La at the time but the
Run would be up like in the North North
I mean the the Northwest like a
California above California so you you I
had to drive back which was like
a 13-hour drive from L.A and I played
Winnemucca Nevada
I played Billings Montana
uh Mountain Home Idaho and and this
wasn't in order it wasn't like you work
your way that way it was like you go up
you go way over here next day you way
over here next thing you way over here
I'm like who rotted this [__]
I'm the feature
the guy that was headlining his big joke
he had the word uh spam on his shirt he
had a Spam shirt
and and his big joke was that he was
dyslexic so he bought this Maps sure
I don't remember his name
comic
guy that was
that was old probably 300 days a year he
went from City to City he could easily
have murdered his way across America
nobody would have known and uh
I just remember being impressed by him
at some point I was like I mean we we
come back here can we ride together he
was like nope
this is my thing I like to drive myself
I was like no problem buddy wow but but
it was it was after doing that run I was
like I'm definitely a headline and I'm
never doing this again mm-hmm you know
so I went through that and
um I mean it's so many Ebbs and flows
man I mean you know taking a bus from
from LA to Dallas to feature for George
Lopez
a bus a Greyhound bus and not knowing
the difference between express and local
what is the difference so if you take
the express you you take you drive big
chunks of the trip so you might drive
from LA to
you might drive from LA to San Antonio
that's a big hunk of of the trip and
they're from San Antonio in the Dallas
two big hunks if you take the local bus
you drive from LA
to San Bernardino to
all those you get to Texas uh Midland
Lubbock Waco
uh so it's like a thousand stops they
delivered mail yeah it's crazy it's
crazy so uberpool
it's a giant Uber pool no Wi-fi it was
just you and your thoughts and I
remember I remember riding that that
trip going out and never ride the bus
again
and I haven't okay I haven't rode a bus
anywhere since that trip and that's over
20 years ago
so it sounds like when you do make that
mind shift it just forces a new like
capability out of you almost I I I
probably probably a capability or
or spiritually it just P it's just
you know the the universe just starts
comes to conspire on your behalf it just
start working to help you you know and
um
I wouldn't say that if I hadn't seen it
so many times okay you know I you know
if I wasn't sure I wouldn't say it but
I'm sure that this happens because I've
seen it you know and um so just know man
if you listening to my voice right now
that you got to commit you got to commit
commit you committed to the stage you
committed to your your whatever your
endeavors is so you got to commit again
you will continue to commit throughout
your career
is there such thing as like two too big
a commitment or too small a commitment
like is there a sweet spot you have
found that's that's a good question is I
don't think any any commitment is too
big but I think you can you can
set your goals too small okay
um
like
you you have to and don't get me wrong
you have to have attainable goals
but no goal is too big because you can
achieve stuff that you can't fathom
you know uh Jamie Foxx is a stand-up
comedian he won a Oscar I know that
wasn't on his bucket list
I'm gonna win an Oscar one day no who
knew I mean the guy is a really great
mimic
you know so it will go to show and prove
that he would be able to do what he did
but he probably didn't know he could do
what he did so uh
to answer a question
again no no go no no thing is too big
but as you set those things be be aware
that you know like like I had a friend
of mine she was like I just want to be
able to pay my bills I'm like that's it
you're already paying your bills like
why even ask for that yeah it's a
struggle
you know like my grandmother used to
pray for me she said Lord she said Lord
give give me give Rodney everything he
needs give him just what it needs Lord I
was like no no no grandma dear God I
need some excess I need some I need what
I need and I need some extra
I need some extra and so if you want
abundance if you want extra you got to
ask for it
when we talk about the seven streams of
income and over your career I think this
will be useful for Comics is what are
what are some of the streams you've not
maybe not even that you're currently
using either because over the years and
in the game what are some of the streams
oh man you've had that man I've tried it
all all the merchandise you could do
I've done it
t-shirts I got a t-shirt on right now
did that spam guy shirt
he I don't remember okay I don't
remember I don't think so
oh God I'm I'm the worst
like I've seen guys that are really good
at it Michael Collier is the best
of all time Selling Stuff he'll be
outside of shows I remember he was like
where you going my money where you going
my money and he will call people back
and they'll come give it to give him his
money yeah it's amazing we did a
co-headlining gig which is amazing in
itself because Michael Collier is a
legend a real deal legend for sure and
so we did a co-head line gig in St Louis
together
and I had my little shirts
I'm just like
I hate Hawking stuff I don't I don't
like it too I don't like being in the
mall me neither like I'm a comedian you
know I don't like but when you watch
this man first of all
he wraps his set and then he pitches for
20 more minutes
the pitch is unprecedented like and then
he has he has all this stuff that's so
easy he's not carrying a lot of stuff he
has a book he has a sheet of paper
with a poem on it
it's seven dollars
[Laughter]
it's amazing he has something else he
has a button or something
they all cost these individual prices
but together
you can get the love package
for 35 dollars
you know people run to get his man his
35. and I was sitting I was in awe I was
in all and so
um but I've tried I've tried a lot of
different things
um but t-shirts merch requires you to be
there I hate Merchants attached to a
joke because now now I'm forced to do
that joke every set you know so I hate
that but I've tried that I've done uh
wristbands and key chains and CDs and
DVDs and that's become obsolete so
everybody's trying to figure out what's
next is the digital downloads what is
the thing uh podcast
uh live radio Blog Talk Radio I have my
show over there for quite some time uh
those could be streams of income as well
uh
what else have I done you know inside
and I've written
uh okay most recently I um I did punch
up on the film which was very
interesting to me because I was punching
up stuff for comedians so they had
comedians on the set and I was giving
them lines and stuff it was really
interesting and rewarding on another
level but it was just another way to um
to kind of maximize what we do because I
mean like like when you when you're
talking with somebody over the phone and
you helping them punch up a set that's
no different than punching a movie right
you just got to be good on your feet and
you got to be willing to for it not to
work and you just got to keep keep
throwing down keep throwing keep
shooting keep pitching so uh I've done
that
um
warm-up was big for me
audience warm-up was very big for me
um Kim Whitley gave me my first warm-up
job
and So for anybody that doesn't know
what warm-up is right
um
most TV shows have a live studio
audience well not as much anymore but
like all the sitcoms in the in the 90s
would have a live studio audience and so
whether it was all of us Will Smith show
or you know or The Bill Cosby Show the
uh The Cosby Show they all had live
audience so there's a human being that
keeps the audience engaged while they're
shooting the show
I was one of those guys Cedric the
Entertainer gave me a great job he had a
sketch comedy show
and uh it was called Central
entertainment presents I was I was the
woman guy and it was great I was getting
fifteen hundred dollars a day that's
great and I was getting two days a week
oh you talk about Rodney Perry buying
the drinks what
what give them whatever you want man
dude and I was living in L.A so to make
that type of money and live in L.A I
could pay my rent it was it was just I
mean and I was I was making maybe seven
eight thousand miles a month that's
great and I mean this is years ago so
that that sustained me for quite some
time and uh you know Cedric also gave me
my first movie that's when I realized I
needed to act
because
if you want to be a stand-up comedian
and you want people to come see you they
need to know who you are
one of those ways that people become
familiar with your television and or
film and so I that's why I started
taking acting classes so I started
taking classes I knew that I wasn't just
naturally good
I knew that so I said let me take a
class and let me figure it out a little
bit because I'm going to get these
opportunities so sometimes you got the
anticipate where you're going and what
you're going to need and start getting
those things pulling it in you know
putting those things towards you and so
I did that but you know man outside of
stand up I've done a number of things to
earn money though you know but it's
always in the stand-up or a comedy world
right in my mind yeah yeah and it's
important for comedians to understand
that some of those require investment
absolutely like you need to oh yeah I
need okay I'm gonna want to become an
actor okay well I need to do acting
classes I need to pay to take acting
classes like there is some upfront now
let the buyer beware
there there's a business of people
separated you from your money so if
anybody asks you for like a thousand
dollars off the rip it's a rip-off
period
I've been ripped off
oh yeah it's like have you seen these
Billboards even right here in Atlanta
there's some Billboards right it's like
Christians that want to act or something
like that oh yeah yeah it's a rip-off
it's a rip-off looks like it it's
absolute ripoff and Barbizon you know or
you ever been in the mall and somebody
goes your daughter your kid is so
beautiful and you're like my kid
my kid is regular my kid is not like
that but bring her in and then you get
in and they start telling you well we
got to take pictures well just give us
800 and we'll get it started rip off
okay it's Ripple and there's tons of
companies like that and so uh I remember
when I was in the Navy me and my buddy
they had told us we could all be models
let me tell you something Rodney Perry
in my mind I'm handsome but I know the
truth
and we I'm not a model I'm 5'7
but Stout these schools
I'm like a fire hydrant
you can't push me off
yeah so it sounds like as well as we
land This Plane here a lot of the
opportunities you've discussed have come
from your network like a lot you're like
said got me this Kim Whitley booked me
on this and absolutely Even in our first
interview we did together you were
talking well you were talking about how
Kevin Hart stole all of your friends he
still owns my friend
they're like writers for him and part of
his team and everything yeah but but you
know the the network is very important
man you're in your network and I
remember me and my buddy Joy Wells it's
standing outside of the Improv one day
and we was just looking uh it was
comedians like Alex Thomas and and uh
Chris Spencer and all those guys were
they just looked like they was having
fun and we was looking like man how do
we get in the click
how do we get in that click those guys
are clicking yeah how do we get in there
and what we learned is that you kind of
don't get in the click you kind of
become the click
like your boys right now your friends
your Associates your peer group become
The Clique and people are going to be
looking like Joe Byers and those guys
with the doubt we want to be them so
you'll be eventually become The Clique
and so you don't join those people are
gone like cats come to me all the time
and Miss Rodney I want you to Mentor me
well first of all you don't get to pick
your mentor
your Mentor picks you
you know just walk up to Sensei and be
like Sensei let's fight
no buddy
but so so so now he
when you when you when you're when
you're making these steps and these
strides and and you have a master's
network over your career you know people
chose you Cedric chose to kind of help
me a little bit Kim Whitley chose to be
my friend which because like I tell cats
all the time be my friend dude
if you're my friend when stuff crosses
my desk then I'll call you
it's just kind of what it is and don't
be afraid to ask for help
I'll leave that don't be afraid to ask
for help like
people look at you Joe buyers and they
think you got it together and you do
but you need help sometimes
you know people see you doing this and
they go like yo man Joe buyers he don't
want a feature
you know but we talked the other night
and for the first time I thought I was
like Yo Joe will be a dope feature for
me you know but I didn't even know you
were in the market
now I know so sometimes it's like yo uh
you know you can't be afraid to go hey
man if you have any future work let me
know and then the guys that say that
ain't even ready
they said they want a feature oh man I
get like a young girl hey hey Rodney I
heard you you think uh
Maybe
you know so
um I like to think that that the cats
and and notice it's not a forever job
like I featured for some great comedians
you're you're working your way out of
that job the moment you take it
the moment you start featuring for
somebody you he should he or she if he
loves you if he likes you he should tell
you one day that's it dog it's been it's
been a good run you know if he wants you
to you win if you stay in that spot too
long it's not productive for you or him
you know we all need to be challenged so
yeah yeah that's where my mindset just
shifted this year I just became in the
market on that level where I'm like okay
I'm at least this I'm no longer like
well chip away it's like no I'm now this
right so when that came up in
conversation we were out of the show
maybe you were one of the first people
actually maybe audibly expressed it to
also so like you said it's kind of make
the Mind shift and then kind of we run
into each other at a show and then this
happens and then you know so there you
go maybe it is Boom
Divine hey now we gotta do is get one of
these shows get you out here on this
road get a date yeah yeah so it's coming
I promise I promise you at least one I
mean I appreciate anything man so maybe
a good closing piece of advice for
comics and like networking is a big deal
but you can also be annoying when you're
trying to network when you're out at
shows and I know you're because you are
so approachable I mean I before I even
really knew you I hit you up on Twitter
and I was like hey you want to go see
Louis CK at the fox I wouldn't even know
each other really to this day that is
probably one of the best hit-ups anybody
ever gave
especially considering you know what
Lewis and is going through right now
which I which I'm you know it is what it
is but what do you think about it
I mean
the man likes to masturbate it's okay I
do
like I masturbate all the time I just
don't do it in front of people and I get
you know the metoo movement I get it but
you don't go to a guy's room at two
o'clock if you don't want to see his
penis um
at 2 A.M penises come out
sorry ladies it's a fact in life what
about the set that was leaked where
people are saying like his material
about like the Parkland shooter and all
that he's always been that guy this is
the thing Joe buyers people don't do
anything new
people nobody
people kind of do what they do all the
time so
where America is now we kind of like
when we like it but we don't like it
it's it's it's it's it's hurtful you
know so you don't get to have it both
ways either you hate him when he's when
you like it and you hate him when you
don't like it you don't get to do both
and so that's the frustrating thing and
what I'm concerned with as a comedian is
any comedian that comes Under Fire for
saying or speaking their truth whatever
that thing is when you have a thought
don't get me wrong Parkland is kind of
one of those things I personally might
not do a joke about it but because he
found a way to make it funny it's
interesting to me
that's interesting to me you know like
if I'm if I'm on stage and I see a guy
in a wheelchair
how dare I
not say what I would say to able-bodied
person to him
how dare I that he he he he he goes
through his life nobody ever people
ignore you
so to have somebody pay attention to you
that might be the blessing in itself you
know I was in a wheelchair for a period
of time I'm telling you there's nothing
more frustrating than people looking
over you
you know and so I was that guy so I get
it if you're in a wheelchair I'm talking
about your ass too was that when you had
a stroke yes you're in the yeah because
that happened since the last time we did
this yeah sure it sure did oh my God I'm
two years removed right now two years
and some change uh uh it's crazy because
you uh you go through a life-changing
moments so I'm probably more spiritual
now than I was then or earlier and
um
and so uh you know I tell my buddies I
had a chance to look over the age
the edge of life like oh
wow it's crazy
you know I had a chance to die I didn't
die
but
the things that happen to a person that
dies I was able to see that while I was
still breathing you know when a guy dies
and everybody posts pictures like like
how cool you were and stuff like that I
saw that
no people were doing that for you yeah
while I was in hospital people were like
yo Rodney Perry once told me XYZ or
Roddy Perry Oh my God you know it was
crazy and I was like yo they talking to
me they talking about me like I'm dead
like hey I'm over here
yo yo it was crazy and so you go through
that and um this is the best part about
getting sick
I looked amazed and I lost so much
weight
[Laughter]
I'm trying I'm trying I'm thinking about
getting sick again just as [__] about
35. what what would what like having a
stroke what is that like like where did
you think you were gonna die
never okay I never I never but but I'm
an idiot
the best thing I had going for me
is that the best thing I had going for
me is that I didn't know how bad it was
had I known how bad it was I probably
would have been easily I would have felt
sorry for myself but I was still trying
to make shows
I was like yo I know we got rehab
tomorrow but can you just get me out of
here in like seven days I got a show in
Atlanta
you taught me that important lesson we
were I was on an open mic like not a
great open mic and then I saw you there
and I was like what are you doing here
and you were like I'm a comedian I'm a
comic you're like you like looked at me
in the eye and smiled and said I'm a
comic and I was like yo that is the
lifestyle I'm also a crackhead I'm a
comedy crackhead every comic is not that
guy I am like I'm a fiend I need it I
need it it's for my own psyche it's very
selfish I need it and
um when comedians reach out to me it's
like man I think I want to do comedy you
got to get on stage for me you got to
know you love this then we can figure
out other means of what your next step
is but you you like you you gotta you
gotta take some steps on your own before
I help you
so maybe Comics trying to network make
sure when you're approaching someone
like a Rodney Perry or even like just
another comic like make sure maybe you
have
don't just annoy them and like trying to
take from them maybe bring something to
the table
um I mean it's a field thing it just
needs to feel right you know like uh
like Benny Pitts is a guy I like
but Benny don't work hard enough for me
so where I like Benny and we we have a
cool relationship like he called to
check on he called check on me but I
don't give any comedy stuff
because Benny Benny is not dedicated to
stand up like that and hopefully he
watches this and goes but Rodney I am
and I'm like okay when the last thing
you've been up any hmm
it's too long if you had to look right
up yeah too long yeah yeah you know so
um it's uh it's definitely uh you can't
annoy me because I won't let you
so I just shut it down if I want to deal
with you I just shut it down so just
treat it treat it like a a working
environment and just be a good co-worker
just exactly be a good Colo be a good
co-worker great great well said okay
good well we got that out of there all
right Comics be a good co-worker this is
a business treat it like one treat it
like one it's your business you own it
hey that that was the whole goal this
talk to was business and you gave it to
us so I appreciate it man amen thank you
and uh
before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
oh the um Rodney Perry Survivor is on
the streets it's my new uh comedy uh I
guess a CD album great maybe okay
um I'm really proud of it it's uh the
cover is uh old to the Great Richard
Pryor had a pencil drawing made in my
face and so the cover is Ode to Richard
Pryor wanted uh live in concert I
mimicked that cover but it's Roddy Perry
Survivor and uh it's it's out now I did
an interview on Tom Joyner uh yesterday
about it and um I'm really proud of this
piece and you know so after having the
stroke
I really wanted to to kind of um
put this material out I was ready to
shoot video but I wanted to get it out
to the world so I did this CD and we
shot right here in Atlanta we recorded
right here in Atlanta for the at the
Atlanta comedy theater uh and it's for
sale uh if you want to get one it's 7.99
on iTunes or all the places Google play
all the places you buy music and uh so
uh and it'll be available for streaming
I think next month if you want to wait
and you just keep
is there is there stroke like you talk
about the stroke oh yeah tons of stroke
material I'm the stroke comic stroke
King
that's stroking hashtag oh nice hey
Brandon somebody said to me when I was
in the hospital it was so funny you see
right now I heard you're starring in the
Clarence Carter story
Clarence Carter is a blues guy years ago
he had a song called stroking
I said what
that's when Comics are your friends oh
yeah I talked to my Michael call you
earlier Michael called me Michael
Collier called me every day when I was
in the hospital and told me a joke
every day
I'd probably let you know like the
impact you're having on the world when
you when something goes down like that
in the amount of Outreach he was a very
nice and generous for that
I did get tired of it
I was like if this [__] caught
me one more time I'm gonna kill it if
you're like this guy's a comedy Legend
but if he calls me one more time he
gonna be a dead Legend
well we'll also link up all your your
social media and all that absolutely
show notes because it's all Rodney Perry
live yes I believe so everything Rodney
Perry writer yeah my website is Rodney
Perry okay it's either Rodney Perry or
Rodney Perry live on everything okay
well we'll be sure to link that in the
show notes and uh hot Brethren and
sister and what you just witnessed
Rodney Perry sharing all of his advice
and experience over the years all the
stuff he's learned the hard way so you
don't have to all right you're still
gonna do it the hard way though you're
like well that's the thing about that's
what I love about this podcast and you
know people will come on here and not
withhold information which a lot of
people like to do for some reasons
withhold information but it's like
people can get the the sauce but they
still have to cook it you know you still
have to cook it so wow this you got some
Jewels yourself Joe Byers you think so
sauce cooking what that was amazing well
Carlos Miller had a good quote on here
where it was he said um people can have
your people can have the recipe but
they've got to know how to cook it or
something like that right like it's
there's different chefs have different
styles exactly you're artists man your
artists you know we just want to paint
so that's what we want you to do hot
Brethren and sister and leaving this
interview if you did enjoy this and you
found it valuable and educational just
share it with another comic that's all
we're trying to do here is help you suck
less at comedy help you suck less at
comedy and get some success
bars so Rodney Perry did that with you
today if you found that educational just
share it you can leave an iTunes review
what you did enjoy about it if you want
to hear someone interviewed on here hit
me up all social media at hot breath pod
hotbreathpodcast.com is the website
joelbyerscomedy gmail.com is my personal
email if you want to reach out and
connect and schedule a writing session
or just let me know something else you
want to see here on the podcast but
we're a community we're a network
building together and that's how we're
gonna get where we all want to be and
it's a network so the big takeaway today
net work treat comedy like a business
when you go out to a show that is your
work place be professional be a good
co-worker and Rodney Perry you've been a
good co-worker today my man thank you
brother all right JB in the building
signing off
[Music]
yeah well you know I'm trying to
make something nice here
[Music]
High breath